المقاطع والصور المؤلمه لضحايا وجرحى
ودمار الزلازل كثيره لكن رغم الالم
والتعاسه لمالي الاجواء في كثير منها في
على الجانب الاخر مقاطع كان فيها نهايه
سعيده فقرتنا الجايه مخصصينا لمقاطع من
هذا النوع يعني لعل وعسى ناخذ جرعه من
الامل وسط كل هذا الالم اللي جالس بيصير
حوالينا في مقطع انتشر حول العالم لطفل
حديث الولاده طلعوا من تحت الانقاض في
جنديرس في ادلب
الطفل رضيع هذا اتضح انه بنت بنت ولدتها
امها تحت الانقاض واثناء ما كان الناس
بيبحثوا عنا جين سمعوا صوت بكاهه ولقوها
والحبل السري ما زال موصول بوالدتها اللي
للاسف
توفيت مو بس الام حتى الاب وباقي افراد
العائله توف وهو الرضيعه هي الوحيده اللي
نجت وحاليا في حضانه في احدى المستشفيات
بتعاني من خدوش في وجهها واضلاعها لكن
بشكل عام حالتها مستقره وفق الاطباء رغم
العشر ساعات اللي قضتهم تحت الانقاض قبل
ما يتم انقاذها
هاي البنت في معك قدمي شديده على الظهر مع
التورم يعني غالبا متعرضه على بحث من تحت
العقاد متعربه لضغط او ساقط على اي شيء
قدمي كتير واضحه وكتير كبيره فيما كدمات
بالاذن بالوجه بالجبهه في كدمات والاضلاع
نور طفله اخرى مقاطعها قطعت القلب لما
كانوا بيحاولوا ينقذوها وهي عالقه بين
الانقاض ولكن نجح واخيرا في اخراجهم
ما شاء الله ما شاء الله
الحمد لله على السلامه يا عمو
شوي شوي على الحديد
تمام تمام الله يجزيكم الخير يا رب بسم
الله
في مقطع ثاني كمان اثر في الملايين لطفله
واخوها مو بس علشان كانت حاضنته وحاميه
راسه تحت يدها لكن كمان بسبب الكلام اللي
قالته للمنقذ وهي بتترجى يطلعها
الناس لما انتشرت لهم صور بعد انقاذهم
وواضح فيها انه حالتهم الحمد لله مستقره
وغير الرضيعه اللي ولدت تحت الانقاض وغير
نور وغير الاء واخوها في مقاطع منتشره
كثيره بتبعث على الامل حتى وسط كل الوجع
والحزن من الكارثه مقاطع بنشوف فيها حالات
انقاذ لناس ومنهم اطفال لهم اكثر من 72
ساعه تحت الانقاض مع هذه الحلقات او مع
هذه اللقطات بننهي حلقه تفاعلكم لليوم
[تصفيق]
يلا يا عم يلا دقيقه دقيقه بس دقيقه دقيقه
يلا يلا
الحمد لله على السلامه الله اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر
[موسيقى]
الله اكبر
الله اكبر يا رب يا رب
الحمد لله الحمد لله رب العالمين الحمد
لله
ما تخاف قول يا رب
انت شامله
كمان
غني لي هلا تغني لك اياها انا
[موسيقى]